THAT.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
NOW I DON’T KNOW ABOUT YOU, BUT
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, I’VE HAD
ENOUGH OF THE PATHETIC ATTEMPTS
BY DEMOCRATS TO TRY TO TAKE
CREDIT FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
BOOMING ECONOMY.
NOW, IT’S A LIE THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS BEEN
PEDDLING NOW FOR THREE YEARS.
>> THE LONGEST STREAK OF JOB
CREATION IN AMERICAN HISTORY, BY
FAR.
A STREAK THAT STILL CONTINUES,
BY THE WAY.
THANKS, OBAMA.
WHEN YOU HEAR ALL THIS TALK
ABOUT ECONOMIC MIRACLES RIGHT
NOW, REMEMBER WHO STARTED IT.
>> Laura: OF COURSE, OBAMA’S
MEDIA ACOLYTES, THEY JUST ECHO
HIS EMPTY CLAIM.
>> TRUMP’S GREATEST
ACCOMPLISHMENT IS NOT SPRING UP
BARACK OBAMA’S ECONOMY.
>> 10% LESS IN JOB CREATION.
>> DID HE DO ANY OF THOSE THINGS
FOR THE ECONOMY?
NO, HE IS BENEFITING FROM
BARACK OBAMA’S ECONOMY.
>> BY JUST ABOUT ANY MEASURE,
BARACK OBAMA’S ECONOMY WAS MUCH
STRONGER.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
EVERY MEASURE?
REALLY, JOE?
WHAT A NOVEL IDEA TONIGHT, LET’S
INTRODUCE A CONCEPT CALLED
"FACTS" INTO THIS EQUATION.
FIRST OF ALL, OBAMA BENEFITED
FROM THE NATURAL RECOVERY
ASSOCIATED WITH A TERRIBLE
RECESSION.
BUT EVEN THEN, ECONOMIC GROWTH
GROUND TO A HALT BY THE END OF
HIS PRESIDENCY.
IT SHRUNK TO A MEASLY 1.6%
DURING HIS LAST YEAR IN OFFICE.
IN 2016, THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
STOOD AT 4.7%.
AND REAL MIDDLE-CLASS WAGE
GROWTH WAS FLAT.
BUSINESS SENTIMENT WAS
RELATIVELY LOW, PROBABLY AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THE $900 BILLION
WORTH OF REGULATORY RED TAPE
FROM THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE WAS
FLAGGING, AS WELL, AND THE DOW
WAS SITTING JUST ABOVE 18,000 ON
THE EVE OF THE 2016 ELECTION.
BUT WE ALL REMEMBER, THAT ALL
CHANGE THE NIGHT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
>> WE WILL EMBARK UPON A PROJECT
OF NATIONAL GROWTH AND RENEWAL.
I WILL HARNESS THE CREATIVE
TALENTS OF OUR PEOPLE, AND WE
WILL CALL UPON THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST TO LEVERAGE THEIR
TREMENDOUS TALENT TO THE BENEFIT
OF ALL.
>> Laura: AND HE MADE GOOD ON
THAT PROMISE.
A BUSINESS SENTIMENT IMMEDIATELY
SPIKED.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE SKYROCKETED
ALMOST IMMEDIATE AND HIT ANOTHER
15 YEAR HIGH LAST WEEK.
AND THE DOW SORTED.
IT’S NOW NEARLY 30,000-POINT --
NEARLY DOUBLE WHAT IT WAS BEFORE
TRUMP’S ELECTION.
THAT’S GREAT NEWS FOR THE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WITH
401(K)s AND IRAs, AND THEN
COME OF COURSE, THERE WAS THE
TAX CUTS.
>> WE HAVE CUT TAXES, TAKEN CARE
OF REGULATIONS, CUT MORE THAN
ANY OTHER PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY, AND WE
DID THAT IN THREE YEARS INSTEAD
OF EIGHT YEARS.
REMEMBER, THE TAX CUT WAS THE
BIGGEST TAX CUT IN THE HISTORY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: IT TURNS OUT THAT
THE MONEY AMERICANS KEPT, WHICH
PELOSI DERIDED AS CRUMBS, IT
BOOSTED OUR ECONOMY BEYOND WHAT
ANYBODY EXPECTED, OR AS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PUT IT, A
WAVE OF OPTIMISM HAS SWEPT OVER
AMERICAN BUSINESS LEADERS, AND
IT IS BEGINNING TO TRANSLATE
INTO THE SORT OF INVESTMENT AND
NEW PLANTS, EQUIPMENT, AND
FACTORY UPDATES THAT SPURS JOB
CREATION AND MAY FINALLY RAISE
WAGES SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND IT WORKED, RIGHT?
UNEMPLOYMENT IS NOW NEAR AN
ALL-TIME LOW, AND THE BENEFITS
OF THIS ARE BEING FELT FAR AND
WIDE.
>> THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS
REACHED RECORD LOWS, ALL-TIME,
NEVER LOWER THAN WHAT IT IS
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: SOME DEMOCRATS JUST
CAN’T ACCEPT THESE AMAZING JOBS
NUMBERS.
>> I’M SAYING THAT THE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT IS
NOT THE LOWEST IT’S EVER BEEN,
UNLESS YOU COUNT SLAVERY.
WE WERE FULLY EMPLOYED DURING
SLAVERY.
>> Laura: WHAT ARE YOU EVEN
SUPPOSED TO SAY TO THAT?
OF THE FACT IS, THE
UNPRECEDENTED PROSPERITY WE ARE
SEEING TODAY IS THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT THE SO-CALLED ECONOMIC
EXPERTS PREDICTED BACK IN 2016.
>> IN THE EVENT DONALD WINS, I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THE
MARKET TANKS.
>> YOU WILL SEE A MARKET CRASH
OF HISTORIC PROPORTION.
>> IF TRUMP BECOMES PRESIDENT
AND IMPLEMENT ALL OF HIS
PROPOSED POLICIES, THE U.S.
ECONOMY COULD TAKE A $1 TRILLION
HIT.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I MEAN, HOW ARE ANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE STILL WORKING AFTER THOSE
PREDICTIONS?
WELL COME INSTEAD OF CALAMITY,
WE ALL KNOW WE ARE LIVING IN THE
BEST ECONOMY IN DECADES, AND
MOST AMERICANS KNOW WHOM TO
THANK.
A NEW GALLUP POLL, AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER, FOUND 62%
CREDIT TRUMP WITH THE BOOMING
ECONOMY, COMPARED TO JUST 51%
WHO SAID THIS BECAUSE OF OBAMA.
NO WONDER DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING
TO STEAL THE ECONOMIC LIMELIGHT.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT THIS
TONIGHT, IF I WERE A DEMOCRAT,
AND I WAS LOOKING AT ALL THESE
NUMBERS, THE CHARTS, GRAPHS, AND
JUST THE FACTS ABOUT WAGES GOING
UP FOR THE LOWER INCOME
AMERICANS, THE MIDDLE INCOME
AMERICANS, I WOULD WANT TO TAKE